welcome to the weekly poll as usual I'm
Benny from comic story and that is Drake
from comic Dr and trailer Drake that is
s from the TV Little House crew and that
is Rob from Marvel explain and this week
we've got Scarlet spiders Spider-Man
20099 Catwoman bat mini Journal five
more months to live I still don't know
what's going on in that story line the
Red Lanterns are fighting the Gods go
figure Earth Two Worlds End the Futures
and Guardians of the Galaxy and I
dropped my books we're good that's
everything I got that I haven't read yet
there's some other books that came out
but I already put them into my back
little area thingy back door love making
uh
anyway all right great intro as usual
Welcome to our show uh there is Rob
there is s there's Drake there's me and
this week there's nothing to talk about
because nothing happened so thank you
for joining us we'll see you next
week there a crazy
amount amount of Indie books at right
now but like who who cares apparently we
don't care nobody not reading any of
them so okay so today this week when we
decided to hey hey hey Invincible is
freaking amazing so screw you I don't
really even consider Invincible to be an
indie book at this point I don't
consider anything Robert Kirkman does to
be an IND exactly it's Kirkman it's
image it's been around for like over 10
years that's pretty much a main stay
right I mean it's it's kind of like the
Scott Snider Indie book they're all like
Scott Snider doing an indie book I'm
like it's not really an indie book like
everyone's going to buy witches it's
like is every like is Quinton Tarantino
movie like are those all Indie I mean
like they could still be is is witches
based on like the book from back in the
day from like the movie with no
completely no
noes of Eastwick so what we've decided
to do that since this is the case what
we're going to do is tell you guys each
of our what we consider to be the best
story arer or our personal favorites so
that the other three guys in the podcast
can tear it up that's pretty much the
entire plan and over the course of this
podcast when we get to the end we're
going to go through we're going to talk
about your all's favorite stories so
like hit us whatever the comments are
put yeah put in the uh put in the the
stream like tell us what your favorite
story arcs are in Marvel or DC Comics
but bear in mind this is an hour and a
half podcast and we're not going to be
here for four hours so yeah that's not
going to happen one of my I also do want
to State and take advantage of the
beginning of the podcast to state that
we are launching the weekly poool uhet
it's net right yeah it's something yeah
do something the weekly pool.net right
right now there's a placeholder for it
but it's going to be the content of
myself comic Drakes uh TV Little House
Marvel explained it's super effective
and some other people that we're talking
to we're going to bring you the Premier
Source of comic book entertainment
YouTube videos that's what we're aiming
for this is going to be a place for a
community there's going to be some
forums there's going to be a chance for
people to contribute if they want to be
a part of this um we're letting you guys
know now even though it's not launched
until January 1st because we want you
you guys to submit as writers for it as
content creators for it as Forum mods
and what I need you guys to do is email
us at comicstorian gmail.com s tvhouse
docomo at norex
plain.cssux it's catch all I like that
let's do it all in front yeah well I'll
I'll do I'll do some stuff on your back
end too later of of the Marvel explained
back end
but
said all right so that's what he said to
her I don't know and unless unless Sal
and Robert are gonna uh disagree I feel
that we should let Drake go first of his
favorite story because we may lose him
in 10 minutes I agree I think we we
almost already lost it right now I think
D I think Drake's Frozen in time okay
for the record everybody just so you all
know he has literally been fine for the
last 30
minutes why don't you tell us your
favorite story wait he's talking you can
hear him oh are you there are you
you oh God ohang on did you guys get my
little freak out we got the tail end of
it the tail end okay that yeah okay good
as long as you got that in there why why
are you perfectly fine for the last 30
minutes we go live and it's like and D
gone pretty much he's gone again so s
why don't you tell us what your favorite
story to start things off maybe it's uh
pressure from all that
um Drake hold off we're gonna go a sound
while while your connection resolves
itself
okay all
right um all right I don't know like I'm
gonna I'm gonna toss this out to the
group is this technically a story arc
I'm going to go with Dark Knight
Returns yeah I can say it's a story arc
doesn't have to be in the in the stories
you know I mean it's technically an
elor's title so it doesn't really take
place in continuity but um doesn't to be
in continuity though my my storyline is
out of continuity so okay there you go
uh I will allow it because I'm doing the
same
thing excellent as long as there's 50%
of us that are in agreement uh it it
goes through uh
no it's already done what we've already
agreed on it we've already said that
it's it's allowed
but uh I feel like Dark Knight Returns
it's got the like it's got It's got the
Epic scope that I really look for in
like an in a in a mini or in a in a
story arc um it has really great
characterization the art is really sweet
um it's got all it's firing on all
cylinders I mean not to mention the fact
that it's also like one of the most
definitive Batman stories ever written
um defin but and it like changed the
genre but like at the same time it's
also just like a purely fun comic I I
whenever anybody asks me like what my
favorite comic is or what my favorite
like movie is like there's a million
criteria by which I could judge it and I
think to myself like okay what's the one
that I'll always read or watch like
what's something that I always watch it
almost it actually cost me a job one
time because somebody asked me what my
favorite book was and what my favorite
movie was in a teaching interview and I
said my favorite movie was Terminator 2
I said my favorite book was Dark Knight
Returns and I proceeded to by the way
weave an entire web of of [__] where
I explained like how you know
Transcendent they are and how they like
defy genres and they you know and gender
roles and they really blow like blow the
lid off of all their of their respective
mediums but like did I I mean look I'm
not I'm not working there so clearly
they didn't buy it but uh you know but I
feel like that's that's kind of like my
go-to is like the one that I'll always
be able to read and find something
either new or something that just really
resonates with me so Dark Knight Returns
is my number one it's just funny because
like everyone accuses me of being a
Marvel guy or a Marvel [__] or Fanboy I
think that's the term I'm just gonna
accuse you of being I'm gonna call you a
DC hipster that's what I'm gonna call
you yeah everything was cool pre
new2 yeah I like I liked DC before
everything got corporate except it's
always been
corporate because like DC's been owned
by Warner Brothers since like the like
the 70s yeah they they've been but they
all they for the record they almost
never went bankrupt like Marvel just
saying funny was I was reading I was
reading Marvel almost exclusively during
the bankruptcy era and like that was a
hard time those were those SC we were
really worried that Warner Brothers was
gonna freaking buy it and then cancel
every book except for like what was it X
X-Men except for X-Men and just release
Xin books cuz back then even Spider-Man
was not like a huge title like
especially after the clone saga yeah I
think you mean the grown Saga yeah it
was a bad time it was a bad time for all
of us yeah Drake try and try and switch
your get try the emotion plan with your
pictures let's try no it's it's going to
take way too long you're going to hear
lots of clicking furiously like I'm
playing Cookie
Clicker Cookie Clicker so addicting it
is it sucks because you're also so
well-dressed you look the best of us in
this room it's I'm sport in the colors
what in all my videos my my whole thing
is that I'm trying to it's so
ridiculously nerdy and stupid I might as
well just ham it up as much as possible
put on a tie put on a shirt sit on my
damn throne and just talk about whatever
so I try to look the part for the record
Drake apparently the viewers would like
to start a collection to pay for your
internet let's get Drake more internet I
am tot fine
with makes sense I am it's terrible I'm
hoping that the I'm hoping the the lack
of video helps I it sounds like sounds
coming across clear right now we can
resolve something else later okay so
Dark Knight Returns it is I I agree with
you I think it's a pretty incredible
story now the problem I have with Dark
Knight Returns
is it I I a lot of people go to it as
the definitive de facto story of Batman
it changed the era and I don't know if
that's so much the case yes it's a good
story yes it's like a definitive Batman
story but to state that this is the
story of the80s this is the best Batman
story I don't know about that yeah cuz I
mean I I don't like a lot of what
happens in that story really you know
what happens in there bman an old man
Superman works for the government and
Joker's just Joker I mean like well it's
funny because like it it's also not like
a DC Universe book like right and like
everyone's very handwavy just like
dispatched like Hal went to the stars
and Diana went back to her people and
that's it Oliver Queen is now him I do
love that like Oliver Queen got his arm
ripped off by Superman and stuff um oh
spoilers from a 1980 story arc
yeah I haven't actually read it yet I'm
trying get it I know I know we're
talking about DC for once and it's one
of the damn storys that that I haven't
read because I'm trying to read
everything that actually happens in the
continuity so that I can finally talk to
people like I'm an actual comic book
Enthusiast instead of well there was
just one story that's very important
Noster and I I will yeah right there's
one there's one point that that Kenji 21
brought up that I I will defend and then
I'll get back to you Benny which is like
he says year one is actually a better
written story than Dark Knight Returns I
disagree and I'll tell you why hey your
one was [__] man I I like your one's
story but I really don't like the
writing in it there are some cool
moments but like no line in year one can
be
Batman internal monologue when he's
battling Superman and he says it's way
past time you learned what it means to
be a man as he's punching Superman in
the Goddamn face like so awesome and
badass it's so unal you'll never see
anything like that in year one the worst
part of the worst offender for year one
is that everyone speaks in sentence
fragments no one actually completes a
thought they're like could use a
jackhammer on your back or like falling
down a hill like nobody ever actually
speaks a coherent thought in that book
and while you're reading it it's really
visceral and really like like Smooth
it's quick to read but if you go back
and go over it again you're like son of
a [__] could someone finish a thought
or start one because it's just all over
the place uh clearly Miller's playing
with like the format he's trying out
different things narratively but like
and I like the idea of like a running
commentary and but like if you ever want
to know how badly written year one is
watch the year one adaptation movie
because it's almost verbatim and adapted
and it's fraking
terrible well but the counter to that
though is in Dark Knight Returns you've
got moments like Superman standing at
the Rock hello Bruce I love that that's
like that's funny because that's the
image you think of whenever you think of
Superman is him being like and like he's
so full of himself an eagle lands on his
arm hello Bruce how are you doing today
it's been so long you know the
government's going to have me come for
you soon yeah and the reason they are is
because I'm the most amazing man in the
universe and because we romics I because
down economics yeah but okay I mean we
probably shouldn't spend 25 minutes per
trade I'm curious like like explain this
Dark Knight return story to me like like
why like what like what happens okay uh
really really Bare Bones description of
what happens spoilers more or less oh
yes Drake put your fing hard not to
actually spoil it like or
least no go go for it
Dark Night returns is for me it's the
last Batman story um so Grant Morrison
will tell you that the Killing Joke is
the last Batman story but Grant
Morrison's also a fuddy duddy so let's
forget about him for a minute I've
actually been called a fuddy duddy
before and it's not very awesome you're
a funy ddy I was okay you know all right
I'm gonna interrupt s story for a second
yeah go ahead twice a year me and my
friends get together and do a city-wide
scavenger hunt all right there was one
year like we got together and I tried my
best like was doing the best that I
could but I didn't really come through
that much and so like the next year I
got paired with uh with Lindsay and
Brian and Dan I think and um and Lindsay
was like I heard last year you were a
fdy dudy so you better come through this
year and I came through in spectacular
style I did a pole dance at a bar and
yeah I found like a bunch of cool stuff
how much would I have to pay for a rerun
of that you will not see you will never
see that video oh there's a video oh oh
yeah we had to record it yeah oh so if I
search if I do a a YouTube search for
Marvel explain does a pole dance I won't
find you it's on what if I did a search
for fluidic Beats does it it's on a
phone it's it's on a phone like it was
recorded for a phone which she still has
apparently okay yeah so I was like okay
that's kind of well we just need to get
the people that did the happening to do
it yeah you gave us their name we could
just ask them for it well okay you don't
know okay you don't know you're never
gonna find her how do you know let's
let's find out I'm gonna Linkin you
you're G Linkin me they're on the
they're on the Facebook page I have that
you guys don't know
about that nobody knowall no let us know
in the coms I to shut up right
now so anyway yeah uh give it a quick
rundown of the story real fast okay uh
Dark Night returns is for me the last
Batman story uh it's 10 years later make
it easier and easier yeah uh it's 10
years later Batman is retired because
Robin died not Dick Grayson he quit and
became Nightwing but in this story it's
actually before either of those things
happened it's it's it's actually kind of
neat because it like Jason Todd was not
even like wasn't killed yet and I don't
think that Nightwing had become Robin
yet but I don't know about that um or
Robin had become Nightwing but in any
case uh the story is Dick quits Jason's
dead and Batman retired and the city
went to [__] and everyone needs Batman
because it's the 80s and everything
sucks and Reagan is saying everything's
okay but it's not and so Batman comes
back and it's just Batman kind of like
learning that he's old and realizing
that like the world has changed and uh
Batman like inspires people for like
kind of like the first time ever like
for the rest of the time Batman was like
a crime fighter and because he was gone
for so long he he kind of recaptured his
Mythic status of like was there really a
Batman or was it just like people like
on PCP like and Batman kind
of yeah and Batman just kind of accepts
this role of being like a mentor and
being like a Sigil and it's really kind
of cool how like Batman just eases into
this role of being like an FDR type
character uh in fact Jim Gordon Likens
him to FDR on the radio uh during World
War II and being like just this
inspiring like authoritative like father
figure that says like everything's going
to be okay and like Batman is that like
soothing voice in the radio but he's
actually out there like kicking this
[__] out of people now only got FDR
doing that I know that would be a great
comic motorized
wheelchair it's not it's long enough
people are making Nazi jokes we can make
jokes at FDR's expense but like uh
thep so like on the on the inverse side
uh Superman has become a government
stooge and he works for the government
and he try he basically like you know I
work for the government for the US
government and um I get to do
good even though you know it's under the
beck and call of the president you know
uh and Batman's reluctance to um to play
by the rules or to you know follow
Authority or to to any other authority
than himself um embarrasses people in
supposed Authority like Governors and
senators and Mayors and so as a result
like eventually on the federal level the
president's like Superman you have to go
silence Batman and so then you have this
really cool fight and then it
ends uh you know and by the way it like
embodies all the principles that make
Batman who he is like Batman never
murders Batman is you know a detective
Batman is like a thug and a fighter like
there's so many different aspects of
Batman that you get to see in that and
finally it also introduces one of my
favorite characters that has really
never been realized except in the new 52
in the worst possible way and that's
krie Kelly Robin she's horrible she's so
terrible and it's such a disappointment
because you really just don't need to do
like don't do it like if you're going to
do it wrong or if you're going to do it
in any other way other than what they
did in Dark Knight Returns you can't do
it um so yeah you got Carrie Kelly Robin
you got Batman and you even have a cameo
by Green Arrow kind of he loses an arm
that's cool enough he does and he loses
it by the way off panel like you never
actually see him lose the arm that sucks
yeah but what DC is known for Batman and
ripping off arms you know it's funny you
should say that because DC that is like
a Trope of DC's is losing arms maybe
that's like the first time that a DC
character ever alluded to losing an arm
actually lost an arm look that up yeah
um all right so I mean that that's
that's why you like that story that's
what the story is about Rob what do you
think what do you what do what is your
opinion of dark never turns off of that
Bree
syalis
um Marvel still makes better Comics I
agree I mean I like but you know what's
funny Marvel has never wow me with a
graphic novel like DC's elor's books
I've never seen like a really really
good Marvel equivalent and what if
doesn't count did you never man kills
that's not an elor's book that's Inc
continuity and that could be undone by
continuity that's that's all ongoing by
the way God loves man kills is still an
awesome typ X-Men story in fact it might
be one of the most definitive X-Men
stories but it's not a collected
independent
autonomous it doesn't take
okay I got this I'm going to I'm going
to end this AR right now no I'm ending
an argument that you just started right
there right here right now who is better
Marvel or DC Marvel I am going to de
facto end this officially for all of the
universe right here right now they're
both equally awesome because they're
completely different well de facto in
the podcast because Marv facto boo cuz
Marvel always tries to make things
realistic you have realistic characters
you can relate with they give you
stories that that supposedly Could
Happen although I don't know how we can
even try to try to Warrant the
Multiverse and death of wver [__] but
whatever they always try to ground
things to Earth and the characters are
more on a realistic level so you get
realistic stories you get characters
that you can relate with stuff like that
while DC takes comic books in a totally
different direction they take it to
these are your Gods these are our
characters of fiction that in a thousand
years people are going to look back on
and be like well they worshiped a guy
with a big S on his chest and a guy with
a Spider-Man mask
that's how DC takes it they're
completely different styles of stories
yes DC might have a story in which we
travel through time and we destroy the
entire Multiverse or you know uh Batman
can kill Superman or something crazy or
Superman is considered a God that could
turn into doomsday and then give brain X
powers and punch a hole in the goddamn
universe but Marvel has stories where
Peter Parker has to deal with having a
girlfriend and Aunt May like come on
like they're different worlds yeah
that's the thing you know what's funny
I'm going to tell a quick story I'm
sorry we have to do this but it's but
it's kind of interesting because I was
talking to Joe I was talking to Joe cada
a couple years ago just swinging it just
dropping that name um it was right after
one more day and I contacted Joe Casada
and he like out of character got back to
me and he was like and we talked for a
little bit where I was like you like you
did this wrong and I hate to say that
because like I want you to give me a job
one day but I'm so in like upset about
this I have to torch that bridge by
telling you that you've got it wrong
because you know what you did with uh
and it and it shows because he's like
okay he goes no Superman and he compared
Spider-Man to Superman and he said you
know we have to undo the marriage with
Spider-Man because the reason why
Superman is interesting is because like
he's and he named a whole bunch of
different reasons but one of the things
he said was like he liking Spider-Man to
Superman being an iconic um Everlasting
like undying perpetually young character
that's true and like he goes you've aged
Superman Superman by being married like
you've you've kind of ruined the
Superman character by making him married
and so we're kind of like trying
to elevate Spider-Man to that level
because we think he's pretty much on the
same level and I'm like no Spider-Man
and Superman are not the same character
and they're not on the same level like
even though Spider-Man may make as much
money or more money than Superman uh
media media wise like Superman will be
around in a thousand years Spider-Man
could be around in a thousand years but
the Spider-Man will only be around in a
thousand years if there are young geeky
people who will relate to that character
like who will relate to that origin
story Superman is a myth Spider-Man is a
guy like they're two different universes
and they're two different like
sensibilities true you know there that's
what illustrates for me like the
difference between those two companies
um or those two universes that said I
think you could actually have both of
them like well it's just my argument
everyone always says this is better this
is better this is better and and while
yes they do steal from each other here
and there they're literally two
different companies with two different
styles of doing stories two different
Arts two different superhero types well
I always say like you have the gods
versus the modern man like the the
common man and you know what the common
man is not a bad story but neither is
the god story yeah they're both good
just because you don't like a particular
superhero's power set or abilities does
not automatically say oh DC's [__] cuz
Superman's all powerful it's like saying
like American lit is better than British
lit like or vice versa like oh British
litter is better than American lit
because British literature has been
around longer like that's that's inan
like art is Art and it's all subjective
like the fact is you know it's you're
not gonna like some stories you're gonna
like some other the stories you may
relate better to Peter Parker or Captain
America or Tony Stark than God Superman
but that's what they're going for they
don't want you to relate to Superman
they want you to view Superman on a
pedestal Batman's not a man Batman is
the world's greatest detective that's
what he is he will get out of any
situation you know that as a Batman fan
but and that's that's one problem we
have with the god side on the flip side
though Marvel's got a guys who are going
to get their asses kicked and your God
character is g to be killed I mean it's
yeah well let's also not forget that
there's both types yeah well there's
both types in both
companies yeah exactly like both
companies have the same have all similar
archetypes and they all like hit on the
same points too it's why I don't really
like it's why I can never really make
that kind of con I can never say like oh
well one's better than the other like
they're both doing the same stuff yeah I
like both equally but I happen to like
more of what DC produces I just it just
so happens I like more of their titles
at the moment Marvel could come up with
more stories that I like but yeah that's
just why I read more DC because it just
has more that appeals to me I'm
literally on the same inverse as that
like I feel the exact same way I'm also
just like I like I just happen to like
what Marvel's doing more than what DC is
doing right now and that and that'll
flip I guarantee you three or four years
there's going to be some DC story out
there that you're going to be like man
DC's killing it over Marvel right now
just cuz they have a what also comes
down to is who has a more engaging
storyline right now MH cuz you can take
the greatest heroes and give a [__]
story you can have the X-Men sitting
around having tea you can have a story
where the X-Men take over the world and
everyone's super engaged then you can
have a stupid story line that takes up
like six months about the will of
Professor Rex and no one gives a flying
rat's ass yeah Rob what were you gonna
say here's here's the thing about yeah
like like nobody would [__] let me
talk man um all right here's the thing
about Superman like here's here's the
inherent difference between Superman and
every other character ever like Superman
reflects a Changing Times like look at
Golden Age Superman and then look at
like New 52 Superman like I'm not the
most in-depth DC comic book reader but
the problem with Marvel is Marvel's
characters like the majority of Marvel's
most popular characters were established
in the Silver age the mid1 1960s or the
early 1960s up until the late 1970s and
then some characters came after but like
the majority of Marvel's most popular
characters came during that time period
the X-Men cyclops and so on and so forth
you know Spider-Man and and uh Thor and
Iron Man and all that kind of stuff they
all came during that time period
Superman and especially Batman I would
say more so than even Superman came
around very early at a time when Society
was still like Antiquated relative to
way to the way it is now like you look
at that era in society and those
characters reflect that era in society
you look at like the 1950s and they
reflect the 1950s you look at like the
19 197s 1980s and so on and so forth and
they reflect that time period like you
can literally start at the beginning of
of Superman's entire chronological run
and I guess if you so chose and had
Limitless time on your hands read every
major
story up until the is that what you're
doing well I mean up until the current
day and you could literally see time
change as the stories progress you can
see Society changing and I think that's
that's one of the reasons why Superman
will remain Timeless not necess I mean
he's the you know archetype for
superheroes but more so than that like
he will always reflect the particular
point in time that he is in and and
people can literally trace the
progression of like American history
from the 1930s up until now by just
watching Superman's Comics or reading
Superman comics which is interesting to
me so well I mean at the same time
though Marvel does Marvel goes I love
how this is supposed to be our favorite
stories and we just got into this
massive debate but I U you can see the
same thing in Marvel though I mean you
got the stories in the 1960 7s from
Marvel and that was about drugs war
against drugs and stuff like that I
remember Spider-Man comics were it's
like Spider-Man's going to teach you
about sex education because this alien
is trying to asinate women like what oh
yeah they did a big sper book that
actually lost the comics code Authority
uh approval which actually taught Marvel
like oh we don't need it to publish
books like we could out about drug abuse
in the in the 70s and and now the
stories are about the the abuse of power
and stuff like that people in Marvel I
mean right now the illumin the big story
because access is [__] no one gives
a crap but the big story going on in the
background New Avengers and stuff is
about the abuse of power the people in
power deciding that they have they have
enough power to control the world and
abusing that power yeah yeah and I mean
they're both The Changing Times I I
don't know who's going to be more of a
long lasting character but the whole
point I was trying to make at the
beginning is this year I mean even movie
wise even movie wise Iron Man 2 is crap
dark knight Dark Knight one was amaz
like IR I don't like Iron Man 2 but but
just saying was pretty good yeah I
enjoyed it okay fine whatever fine Iron
Man 2 is amazing either way what I'm
saying is everyone's going to have their
Awesomes and they're going to have their
their shits and they're going to try
things that aren't going to work and
they always end up taking from each
other anyway I mean you can go ahead and
say the new Avengers Multiverse thing is
amazing but DC did that crap in the
1980s called an Infinite Crisis every
World exists and we're going to merge
them and Destroy them and yeah it's
weird that they're doing that now yeah
really 20 something years later they're
like no one will ever relate us to one
of the most de facto DC stories ever
yeah they really need to be careful like
you need to have somebody really smart
write that book yeah and because
Marvel's proven you can't write a book
based on committee like Infinity is a
pile of crap because it was written by
like 20 different people Infinity was
not that
bad was the core book The Core book was
really cool yes except for the end yeah
I I just don't like how they tied
everything in but that's that's a
discussion for a whole another day maybe
think of something else so we can get
back kind of on top here I guess I mean
I guess the facto answer here is pretty
much and all all I was trying to state
is Everyone likes to jump in with these
arguments of Marvel's better DC's better
the fact of the matter is they're both
pretty much the same there's always
going to be something somebody that's
better than the other one it's a fun
argument to have as Fanboys and in the
end of the day image kicks everyone's
ass
so image kick oh
no yeah wild cats and Savage dragon and
the Max and
spawn dude Max a good Max was a good
book 20 issues I I never yeah I never
read the max I remember seeing it on
MTV's Oddities yeah The Oddities cartoon
the only that's the literally the best
way to absorb the max is to watch it is
I remember that all right while we while
we seem to have a solid connection from
Drake Mr guy in an Iron Man suit what is
your favorite story especially I'm
actually really interested in yours
because you're more of a newer comic
reader than the well okay um you guys
are talking about how like image is the
best honestly I would probably say that
the bu ult might war of invincible is
probably one of my favorite uh stories
I've ever read however I cannot even
begin to talk about that because
Invincible itself is a book that's just
built on spoilers and plot twists and
Revelations and if I even give away one
little detail to buite war other than
that hey there's a goddamn War happening
that we learn about at the very
beginning that I'm going to spoil it for
for people so I can't talk about it
otherwise I'm absolutely loving the uh
Injustice Gods Among Us comic it's
probably my second favorite thing on the
market right now and it's just one giant
story and that's that's why I like it
there aren't really any arcs in it and
it's so amazing but if we really want to
go with something that's been done and
stuff I guess maybe the Batman and Robin
run after uh final crisis oh
okay rayson took over as Batman with
Damen yeah because okay listen I I I
[__] on Grant Morrison all the time and
it seems like like I hate him I don't
hate Grant Morrison I just hate how big
in comic Booky all this stuff is final
crisis was just
what the [__] was I reading uh and I
read up to that point as well I read
Batman and son I read uh the black glove
I read Batman rip and they're good but
it's just I didn't understand what I was
reading when I was reading it yeah but
getting to uh Batman and Robin with dick
bat and with Damien uh I I it was more
of a straightforward story yeah it was
really weird and creepy with uh don
Flamingo and with uh Professor Pig and
everything but it it it was still an
interest three three book Arc I guess
you could really call that each book was
their own little thing but overall it
was a a relatively short time of Dick
Grayson as Batman and his relationship
with Damian it was a lot of fun to look
at and then I'm reading through uh Black
Mirror right now and I'm liking it so
great story I just I actually just
talked about that on the the podcast we
just did over on comic story where we
discussed Scot Snider yeah I mean and I
I can't wait to read it because I loved
C of ows as well yeah C of owl is so
good but I honestly I would say the the
dick bat and Robin run was probably my
my favorite of all the story Erics that
I've read excluding invincible and
Injustice and other titles that have the
letter N or I in before the name nice so
how do you feel Rob it's true DC stories
so far
True by a bunch of DC Fanboys so okay so
Civil War is the greatest story ever
because it speaks God no Civil War is
not the no Civil War is not the greatest
Marvel story Greatest Story Ever is the
Spider-Man clone saga because because it
forced a crash in comic books okay to be
fair I actually really do like Civil War
and i' I've been picking up all the side
stories to learn more about it because
I've read Civil War at the core book
I've read uh Fantastic 4 I've read the
Miss Marvel bit of it I just bought
black panther for some stupid reason but
uh Black Panther has one tie in and it's
when him and storm get married like oh
yeah there's no point in buying the
Black Panther for like the tie for civil
war well I like I got it on Black Friday
for half off so why not uh I did like
the Fantastic Four offshoot of Civil War
whenever a thing goes to Paris and just
chills out there for a while and messes
up how to say it's clobbering time in
French how do you say it how do you say
it's clobbering time in French I I
forgot exactly he said it right the
first time the second time he said it he
actually said it's time to
[__] so and and U oh no yeah well the
chick that that that he's with in the
book says uh you said it you said it
wrong you're supposed to say this and
he's like oh I guess I got a little
excited she says clearly clearly but I I
wouldn't translate like oh my God it
really did say that yeah that's awesome
yeah like I mean if if you're going to
get like collections for civil war man
just get like the main Civil War story
and then Civil War Front Line that's
really all you need like everything else
is just interesting yeah so that's me
cool man unless you guys want talk I I
like the same run I actually enjoy I
wouldn't consider it my favorite but if
you've got a smaller pool to go from and
it is a really good run the one you're
talking about yeah I me I've read year
one and I've read blackest Knight black
KN I just find so unrealistic because it
takes place in six goddamn hours yeah no
blackest KN I find unrealistic for a
number of other reasons but but it's a
great story it's a great story and
there's lots of Green Lanterns up in
Reading that's been really good I really
do like the Miss Marvel run right now
with camela con I think it's amazing uh
I can't wait to pick up the new issue
tomorrow and I really am liking Superior
Iron
Man good really see the thing is because
Jason was just going on I was talking
about the Comico story he hates it he he
he feels that it's a forced change on
Iron Man he likes organic whatever it's
axis it wasn't organic at all it was
from what you guys told me Professor X's
mind being hijacked by Hydra and right
school yeah what part of that is organic
nothing oh that's his that's what his
problem is he wanted an organic change
not a hard you know Tony's still aice
bag it's fine yeah yeah it feels pretty
like I mean like I was saying when we
talked about it like Superior Iron Man
just feels like if the movie version of
Iron Man had no redeeming qualities like
he was just a total dick with no you
didn't believe that behind it he was
altruistic yeah well like it's fun but
like see the great thing about Superior
Iron Man is like it goes back to Iron
Man like like focusing strictly on Iron
Man just being an [__] and like
that's what I loved about Tony Stark
back in the day is that seems like it
kind of got lost in the Shelf like
during Civil War everybody's like oh my
God I hate Tony Stark like everybody
hated Tony Stark and then he was they
made him a vill
they made him a v exactly they made him
a bad guy yeah of course you're supposed
to hate him yeah and then after Civil
War like you had U the initiative and
then secret Invasion and all that kind
of stuff and then Tony slarks just kind
of like I mean there's a bigger problem
going on here we'll worry about me later
and then they just never really got back
to focusing on him being an [__] so
I'm really glad that they've they've
jumped back into that because that's one
of the best attributes of his character
like just being a drunk alcoholic
or they've been trying to make him too
goody goody lately in my opinion it kind
of ruins the character of Iron Man it's
like oh he gave up drinking oh he's
going to make his life good oh he's
going to save everybody now you're not
interesting you know he's been trying to
like he's been trying to like redeem
himself literally since Civil War yeah
yeah and like what like it he this dude
has had to do more Penance than Hank Pim
and I gotta tell you like it's kind of
it's enough well no not not really man I
mean like Hank pimp slapped his wife
like Hank pimp his saying I'm saying
Hank Pim hasn't done enough and Iron Man
Has Done way more like Iron Man has like
literally wiped his own mind and like
Hank Pim what changed his costume six or
seven times like that's not really a
fair trade I'm say like when you look at
the gravity of their actions like Hank
Pim like got angry and slapped his wife
like Tony Stark literally split the
superhero Community down the middle and
through superheroes into a prison in the
negative Zone like yeah that's
prettyness well but if you depending on
which book you read whether it's Civil
War or front line like in one of them
the Negative Zone prison is really nice
and in the other one it's guantan Bay so
which one is it in um in the main Civil
War Story like it's this really cool
super technologically advanced place and
then like in front line like they're
living in cages yeah and you're like all
right Paul we get it there's literally a
scene yeah there's literally like a
scene where um where uh Robbie Baldwin
is being taken through like once he's
actually taken captive he's being taken
through the prison so he can meet with
Reed Richards and he passes Goliath or
not Goliath um God what is yeah Goliath
was not in the prison yeah Goliath was I
was dead God I can't I can't remember
the dude's name but he had like a
version of Captain America shield and um
task no not Taskmaster um I can't
remember his name but T Master is my
hero I'm just saying but uh he was like
he was like laying down in the cage with
like a giant piece of shrapnel on his
back and like nobody was doing anything
about it yeah so and there's like it's
like it's gross it's stupid yeah I need
a backrack a little bit anyway is is
Hank Pim really not that much of a
douche in the and the mainline Marvel
stuff cuz I've really only seen him
through the Ultimate Universe where you
know he super beats his wife and attacks
her no the universe he is a bad person
yeah he's a terrible person no he's he's
he's he is but he okay he's all about a
progressing technology to the point of
[__] Humanity okay you like hey if you
just don't make alron we'll never have a
problem but I could make him
better he's like Hank Pim is a hank
Pim I don't know how they really explain
him being crazy but like when he when he
does hit his wife it's one time now I'm
not saying spousal abuse is okay anytime
but I will say that you definitely just
said that in the Ultimate Universe Hank
Pim savagely like beats his wife then
chases her down and sprays her with bug
spray and then commands a bunch of ants
to bite her multiple and now see yeah
and and I I really it's I'm not liking
that part of it but I I do like how they
have wasp talk about uh domestic abuse
after that like oh hey they're conveying
a message I really like that and I was
like oh is he that much of a douchebag
in the main Universe cuz I don't think
I'm going to want to watch that in real
life and whenever Ant-Man comes out yeah
no you know what I think and this this
is completely up topic but I think
that's why we not getting much Hank p in
the main thing because he's so
synonymous with hit his wife yep yeah
every if you bring him into the main
Marvel Cinematic Universe that is what
we're all going to be waiting for when's
he going to hit Janet yeah when he going
to hit his life I mean well I they could
they could write it off and just say
like he yells at her or something like
that but like like it was just simply a
moment in the earth 616 Universe when he
just kind of like lost it for a second
and like hit his wife and then he's not
even like in his right mind at that
point like he's also like crazy and he
thinks these two different people and so
like it's kind of debatable as to which
personality it was it could have been
yellow jacket or it could have been Hank
Pim like you don't really know he does
own it and take responsibility for it
and like at like try to atone for it
throughout his series from then on in
but like and never does it again like
it's every repeat and he always like
it's always thrown in his face at every
opportunity oh because you know Tony
Stark split the entire Marvel Universe
and the Illuminati has destroyed the
entire world you hit your goddamn wife
Hank unforgivable my
God all right so Drake's got a good good
direction it's another DC Book another
Batman book speaking of uh rob you got
to save the day here and if you come up
with the DC Book then I'm just I'm all
bets are off and I'm leaving it's just
the end of that no no no it is not DC
Book my favorite story in the history of
Marvel Comics of all the stories to have
ever been marveled by Marvel Comics
Mar and I believe you did that it is it
is the the Crooked world the I don't
even know that one the the Crooked World
um it is God I mean it's it's old school
like like this was early 80s Marvel UK
so it's it starts out in Marvel
Superheroes I think and then it goes
to God like the Daredevils and then the
mighty world of Marvel like it's it's a
it's it was one of those things where it
was spread over a series of comics but
this is the story of mad Jim Jaspers oh
my God how did I not assume that one it
is my favorite story in all of Marvel
because it was the first alternate
reality story and and it was it wasn't
it wasn't even just like I mean it was
it was basically like like David versus
Goliath but instead of like David
defeating Goliath like another Goliath
came along and defeated Goliath and then
David was just like well I guess I kind
of suck here like that was that was kind
of the story but it was still pretty
cool um I liked it just because it was
the first time Marvel had a character
that had incredible reality warping
powers and so you literally like saw him
warping reality in in the comics like he
was just changing everything around to
the point where it was just absolutely
insane but there's there's one point
where Captain Britain um when his I
guess when he had been killed on Earth
238 by that version of Jim Jaspers and
the Fury and then he comes back to the
regular Earth 616 universe and he's
talking with Merlin who was the one that
sent him to Earth 238 and he was Merlin
was like or you know Captain Britain was
like there's nothing I can do here like
I died you know and and it sucks like
you know I'm sorry I failed and you're
introduced to like the Captain Britain
core and all that kind of stuff and then
Merlin's like well I just sent you there
for like training because now like
you're gonna have to fight the Earth 616
version of MIM Jaspers and he's like a
lot more powerful than the one that you
previously fought and so like like
Captain Britain's just like [__] so so
it's it's it's hilarious like you have
the um God I can't remember what they
were it's not the TechNet but it's
another Bounty Hunter group from uh from
a different dimension that is tasked by
uh Roma and Merlin to capture Jim
Jaspers and when they get in there like
Jim Jaspers is currently um I don't I
guess he's like the prime minister at
the time and um he's sitting in his
office and like when they walk in like
theice office is bigger than it could
ever feasibly be so he's obviously like
warped warp reality within his office
and there's like all kinds of stuff just
like floating there and looking weird
and so they're like we're here to
capture you and he was like whatever and
like he just like totally screws him up
like he makes one person like totally
two dimensional and like it's yeah it's
really cool like all the stuff that he
does but anyway um so Captain Britain
shows up later on after all hell is
breaking loose because he initiates
something called the Jasper's warp which
is literally where it just starts
warping everything around it like starts
warping around and and S didn't give a
[__] s's like yeah that's nice that's
cool yeah like I remember I just yeah
I'm just don't I I want to get the end
of this but what I'm hearing is nobody
of any importance was in this story it's
all Captain Brittain and bety Brad here
like I don't care about Captain Britton
imagine Jas as a man in a diaper but but
it was it was it was super cool because
there's this really cool scene where
where Captain Britain goes to fight Jim
jaff just let me finish my story I
didn't interrupt you you you laughed you
laughed at me
um there's this really funny story where
Captain Britain goes to goes to find Jim
Jaspers and and he he says something he
says like he's it's it's weird or
something like that like he opens the
door and when he opens the door like Jim
Jasper is like 200 feet tall and he's
like sitting cross-legged and looks like
he's out floating in space and he asks
him if he if he feels like he's lost in
the fun house and Captain Britain is
like I'm going to take you down and so
Jim Jaspers basically just starts like
warping everything around cab Britain so
first he's like a kid sitting in like a
a classroom and then like he's somewhere
else and like like it just demonstrates
it's absolutely hopeless like there's no
way that Captain Britain could defeat
Jim Jasper now the way the story ends is
kind of stupid it was disappointing um
you know don't don't because how do you
like build it up like you build it to
this point it's like yeah how do you
solve that how do you defeat how does
Captain Britain defeat like a god Howes
a great all people defeat a god well he
he doesn't like that's that's the
problem like he doesn't like like the
Earth 238 version of Jim Jasper he
created something called The Fury
and the fury was literally a cyborg that
could get could adapt to anything that's
how it managed to kill every superhero
is like it would analyze the superhero
what it was capable of and then like
just adapt itself to their powers so
it's like the Sentinels basically the
super adaptoid is this do this the
invention of that character no it's not
the Super adaptoid like okay so it's not
even a worthwhile robotic character the
theur like this this this is I kid you
not this is like the only appearance of
the fury in Marvel Comics like he comes
back later on you know after to the
House of M and Jim Jasper and fury are
like m in one being but nonetheless like
okay the fury is like the sole survivor
of the 238 Universe after it was
destroyed it had just like adapted
itself to the destruction of the
universe and so what Al what happened is
like Alan Moore and alen Davis were
basically like writing the story and
they got to this point where they were
they asked the same question they were
like well how does Captain Britain like
destroy Jim Jaspers and they were like
[__] it so they just had the fury
somehow know exactly that the Captain
Britain was in the earth 616 universe
and like teleport itself there and yeah
so it sounds characters literally he's
literally a god machine yeah it sounds
to me like looking at your story the
story sounds like it was pretty cool and
then like it was one of those situations
where the writer wrote themselves into a
wall and they were like I don't know I
made God I don't know what Alan Moore
this was alen Moore and alen Davis yeah
like we made God sounds like they should
have figured it sounds like they knew
that to do that like those guys are not
ones to leave it to chance but you're
also talking about like early Alan Moore
and early Allen Davis so yeah I mean but
but nonetheless like the story ends
basically with a furious fighting like
fighting Jim Jaspers and it keeps
adapting itself to all of Jim Jasper's
reality weapon powers and it
rationalizes that in order for Jim
Jaspers to warp reality it needs reality
to warp like Jim Jaspers has he can't
create something out of nothing so he
teleports Jim Jasper to like the void
that is the earth 238 universe and like
incinerates his brain so that's pretty
much How It Ends it was kind of
disappointing but the whole reason why
it's my favorite story is because this
was the precursor to all of the
alternate reality stuff if it hadn't
been for this story none of that like
Days of Future Past wouldn't have
happened none of that stuff would have
happened and it's it's like a really
obscure and really difficult story to
find in its entirety you know like
anywhere in like publication history any
of that stuff I mean it's it's it's
really really tough but it is a
supremely well-written story in the
sense that it lays a foundation for what
can become all that stuff later on like
all the alternate reality stuff so that
that to me that's why it's a really
really cool story The Character suck
like nobody about Captain Britain like
who cares about Captain Britain like
like the British don't even care about
Captain Britain nobody cares about
Captain Britain like the only cool thing
to ever come out of Britain was psylock
like from the superhero community so
nobody really cares about is Captain
Britain Union Jack no okay because I I
listen I was trying to follow the story
I have no idea who anybody you talked
about was and I'm like who the [__] is
this guy by the time I'm I finish
processing that I don't understand and I
don't care
that it's that like I'm done trying to
figure out who it is and just listen to
The Story by I'm done figuring that out
in my brain Rob's already in another
part of the story like okay something
about reality warping I don't even know
anymore yeah yeah no it's like Brian
bradock was an alcoholic um God it's
it's so it's difficult to
remember he because his because he's a
stupid
character it's like who cares yeah who
cares like like he he was an alcoholic
something like the point like that's
that's what Alan Moore does best he
takes a character you don't give a crap
about and he's like here you go
something cool I mean it doesn't sound
like a bad story Rob yeah but um Brian
Brad had somehow ended up in a car wreck
or something like that and he was like I
guess some other alien was chasing after
him or some kind of being was chasing
after him and uh Merlin and roma
appeared to him and gave him the choice
between the necklace the sword of r or
the necklace of miter Amulet of miter
something like that and he chose the
amulet yeah which allows him to like
take on the form of Captain Britain but
then the foe like the bad guy that was
chasing after him chose um The Sword and
then like they fought and then Captain
Britain came out on top and so he's like
the guardian and stuff like that but the
the problem with Captain Britain is
Marvel basically tried to like reach out
to the to like the British Community to
like the United Kingdom community and
create a character the problem here was
they created a character that sucked
like there's there's never been like
there has never been an instance and
even like like like black a car Bol aun
black Bol is like he said that Captain
Britain was uh was cool with Excalibur
and even then I would say that's
stretching it I have never sat down and
said oh my God a Captain Britain comic
like I can't wait to read this like I've
never ever ever SE well I'm about to
rock your world Rob because there is
what no I'm
kidding the most amazing Captain Britain
story ever is the one where he just
didn't
exist a I mean like his his him as a
character is cool and Marvel tries to
like make him cool like in the Age of
Apocalypse he's on the human High
Council and he like he hates mutants and
so like they try to make him cool by
introducing him and stuff and having you
know in alternate realities and things
like that but he's just not a relevant
character like nobody really cares about
him most of the Britain aren't oh wait
what there goes like a whole bunch of
people
[Laughter]
from I just lost half my subscriber Bas
was the one that said it but he said it
on Marvel explains channel so [__]
Rob I'm playing I'm playing I I love
people from England
well speaking of Benny having really
shitty opinions let's hear about his
story oh you guys are gonna hate I I
purpos make the story to piss everybody
off it's gonna be [__] Deadpool and
I'm gonna hate you no it's not actually
oh thank God okay I thought you picking
that cuz you're like you're so gonna be
so excited Drake and like if it's
[__] Deadpool so I could I could pick
a de facto story for Batman killing
jokes amazing Dark Knight Returns is a
good story I could pick an obscure one
that no one else has heard of to go like
Rob and you know talk about some
superheroes that no one knows exist but
it has a personal effect on
me I am going to go with one of the few
giant story changing arcs The Arc itself
was kind of me but what it did was
amazing in comic books the Lash Point
can you I changed my mind that is that
is like probably my favorite story line
that is such a good why are there so
many freaking DC Fanboys in this this is
this is Marvel Fanboy that's what he
does hold
hold flash point itself is a pretty good
story but can you think of any other
time that something completely changed a
mainstream Universe to the point of
completely erasing it like pre New 52
Universe was destroyed yeah thanks s
thanks I mean
like so I mean there's tons of stories
that are are all powerful and amazing
stories to read and I can go off all day
on my favorite stories to read but the
reason I like flasho is because in
flasho first off the flash was a primary
character which I love the flash to put
him in an overarching changing
everything storyline was amazing the
fact that he changed everything and it's
his fault was amazing they didn't just
say oh the reverse flash [__] it up
you have to go change it it was dude you
mess this up you need to fix this and
then the effects of flasho are still
happening in The New 52 yeah that alone
like even if they change it we've gone
three years with the effects from this
event to the point of nothing is still
around we changed everything and it well
until convergence right I was that even
but for three years but you got to think
this had to be the biggest gamble DC's
ever done they've done crisises and
crisis all over but they've never just
rebooted everything from scratch yeah
well they they technically didn't Green
Lantern and Batman still happen in some
capacity I mean I I could go could go on
I mean I love Blackest Night and
Brightest Day if you if you're a new
person to Comics read those read cord of
the owls I could go on about that I
could go on about um freaking Spider-Man
the Ultimate Spider-Man runs amazing I
got that I love so I mean I could tell
you up and down but the reason I like
flasho and I consider it one of the best
stories is because it's one of the few
stories that has had lasting effects
long term yeah and you get Thomas Wayne
as Batman and it's really awesome and
like reading his side story and then
reading uh dead man Grayson's and what
they did with Superman with him uh being
you know a government thing where and
he's all skinny and frail it was just
really really awesome how they did
everything [__] I'm changing my answer
flasho kicked all the ass see Flash and
and here's here's another reason I
enjoyed flasho flasho led directly to
the new 52 which boomed the sales of
actual Comics like crazy that's why I
read Comics because I start I had the
new2 I wouldn't if the new2 didn't exist
I would not be here right now I mean I
mean movies are great they did great for
some sales but the new 52 re restarted
comic readers to such a degree that
Marvel then went with Marvel now and
rebooted themselves to an extent you
know yeah nothing's going to like boost
sales more than saying hey guys don't
buy like 60 years worth of stories just
start here well I know but that is such
a Gamble and that's why I like it I the
story itself I can think of better
stories I mean personally the story that
got me back into Comics out of the Clone
War clone saga was Blackest Night I I
still think it's an amazing story um and
it's one of my favorites but the reason
I like flasho is what it did you know
the story itself really good I like it
but it's probably not my favorite but I
like what came out of it I I like it I
like it too it's not it's not very
bloated the Arts really cool the
writing's not bad the characterization
is good um you know there's a lot to
like about flas point the movie was
awesome yeah the movie was good nobody
continued their stories they all turned
into these alternate universe stories it
was giant gamble for DC yeah I don't
even I I thought that like I'd always
heard that they were just GNA do flasho
as a as a flash story and then they were
like oh you know what we could do yeah
no it was they've said that they were
just gonna do flasho as a flash story
and then they just said you know what
it'd be cool if we just rebooted
everything with this yeah we just
changed off well that's also why we have
our issues with new52 because well
that's why yeah that's why nobody I
guarantee it was it was literally Jeff
Johns and Jim Lee sitting around like
the bar one night like man flash points
going to be awesome we should change the
universe yeah launch that next week
somebody mentioned Marvel before Rob
dies he looks
so uh well mean I mean in Marvel you
you've never had a permanent lasting
effect from a storyline Civil War we've
pretty much moved on from yeah we
mention
it had a longer effect on the Marvel
Universe than flash true yeah yeah but
but it didn't change anything overall
like we didn't get a massive reboot out
of this we just got people that hated
each other yeah it changed everything as
much as nobody gets like nobody trusts
each other and gets along anymore I mean
you've had a massive you've had an event
in uh in Marvel Comics it's had a
lasting and changing effect on the
entire Marvel Universe who
one like they hav they're finally doing
it on
now oh really if you come up with
something involving Howard the Duck I'm
just gonna lie dude like like the birth
of Franklin
Richards yeah that Richard
Marvel is scared to use Franklin
Richards you can't use Franklin Richards
you can't use a character that can do
anything in any story yeah well that's
the problem they created a character
that can literally do everything there's
whole theories that time didn't even
exist until Franklin Richards was there
and that time went all out of whack when
he showed up and like all kinds of crazy
stuff that they just won't confirm
because they made too powerful a
character I mean every time every time
that I make a Marvel story I always get
at least one comment of where was
Franklin Richards during this who cares
yeah that's that's that's why like
vendis killed him off during Age of
Ultron because because you can't have
like some Uber character like Franklin
Richards during the Age of Ultron like
you can't have him going around and
doing stuff because then like like what
do you do but no like no I mean like
after Franklin Richards was born like
Herer stopped aging like all kind of
stuff that happened I mean so I assume
that's a kid of Reed Richards okay
Franklin Richards for the uninformed is
basically the child that and Reed
Richards but the thing is Franklin
Richards powers is basically omn potent
you can do anything literally just think
it in existence control entire timelines
literally everything you
thinkful yeah the beyonder so no not
really see see this is why see this is
why I say you guys need to read some
more Marvel Comics No not Frankl Richard
much of a plot device as the beyonder in
as much as Franklin Richards can do
anything whenever the editors need him
to do anything the beyonder could do
anything because the editors needed
Beyond's been like four different can do
more of anything then no no he can't
like the tears of being able to do
anything like Franklin Richard can do
like 30% of anything wait
created okay how is created Proto
ultimate okay here's here's why Frank
here's here's the thing Drake Marvel and
this is where the theory and Frank wi
come out Marvel progressed at a natural
timeline until the birth of Franklin
Richards as you can look at the comics
as soon as FR I mean like events happen
like super richers was pregnant for n
months of comics things happen in a
natural timeline yeah Peter Parker went
to high school went to college and then
graduated from college like when
Franklin Richards was born everything
started to go out of whack timeline wise
and the running Theory and Marvel has
not confirmed this or nor denied it so
they haven't I mean they haven't gone
either way with this but like the
running theory is that the reason why
superheroes don't age now and everybody
just seems to adapt with the times is
that Franklin Richards is keeping
everybody at the pr like he he's still a
child because he wants to still be that
child and still have the superhero Idols
that his dad is that he can look up to Y
but the problem is Franklin Richards can
do anything so anytime like right right
now in the Illuminati he's talk like
Reed Richard is talking to his daughter
where's Franklin Richards the whole s
this whole time like they pretty much he
just gets removed and that's a part of
his whole concept everyone's like oh no
one knows he exists when he doesn't want
them to when he wants to be older he'll
be older when he wants to be younger
he's younger he can do whatever he wants
like Valeria Richard is a perfect
example of that like Valeria Richards
was like an amalgamation of Reed and
Susan and then she was still born and
then it's like well Franklin brought her
back Frank I wanted a
sister Frank Rich because because
Franklin is a is a stunted child who
like doesn't understand the gravity or
the re or the necessary like the
necessarity of like life and death and
like growing up so like he won't and
like so he plays at being an adult it's
it's really like it's a neat idea yeah I
me he seem he seems really cool just
he's so powerful he's so powerful he
created the Proto Ultimate Universe um
stop me if you've heard this idea before
um Marvel decided they wanted to create
a world where they could tell the
stories with their main characters that
were contemporary and updated and with
new art by new fresh artists like that's
the Ultimate Universe in like
96 the Marvel Universe fought the Beyond
or fought the fought Onslaught Onslaught
kills or rather the X-Men killed them
but it doesn't matter how uh kills the
Avengers more or less and the Fantastic
4 and Franklin Richards says no to that
and then puts them into a pocket
Universe where they could retell all
their old origin stories but in new
modern times drawn by Jim Lee and Rob
lield and like yeah it was oh that's
where get barrel chest Captain America
from that's where you get that crazy
Captain America drawing oh and his
weirdo Nazi like Iron Cross or iron like
Eagle like a a replacement um there were
some cool things to come out of that
Iron Man's suits were neat um Hulk had
long hair like you know Hulk
2099 um but then you know they brought
them back yeah okay like that that was
literally Franken Richards just didn't
want to accept the fact that they died
like it's like it's it's liter like
there's literally it's called The Heroes
Reborn story there's a point where like
one of the celestials appears to him and
it's like these Universe can exist at
the same time like you have to choose
one so he literally enters the universe
that he created and meets with his own
parents and is like I don't know what to
do like I don't know what to choose and
they're like do what you think is right
and so he just goes back and recreates
or I guess eliminates the uh
the yeah and then Marvel launches the
heroes return where they bring back all
the Avengers and the Fantastic for
that's literally what it is yeah it was
a great some of them remember but and so
that's so that's the big thing a lot of
people come up with this stuff because
it's because the '90s book and people
want want you to
forget it was a pretty cool book it was
kind of neat yeah yeah I mean so the
problem with with Franklin Richards is
that nothing's ever been confirmed or
denied flasho was confirmed if if Marvel
comes out and says yes Franklin Richards
is Omni potent to the point of he
affects the time stream and I like this
comment here the reason he never shows
up in events is because he's too busy
holding the time stream
down pretty much he's like well and
someone else asked doesn't he show up in
the distance future yes eventually uh
one of the Futures that kept America
goes to I think it's like 10 billion
years in the future he shows up and
finds an adult Franklin Richards and
grew as a tree like a tree tree whole
tree um which story was that in because
I wasn't it part of that's in New
Avengers uh it was Avengers it was
Avengers during Avengers world or
Avengers the hell I couldn't I couldn't
remember which one it was it was it was
Avengers like 20 or something on the new
on the uh on the original sin story line
yeah I always learned something coming
on the podcast and I'm happy yeah
launched like they they've launched so
much new stuff like you have like the
mighty Avengers and cuz cuz there was a
time where uh where Carol Danvers
fractured off and formed the mighty
Avengers or she was part of the mighty
Avengers I think she was she was as Miss
Marvel she like kind of almost sort of
led the mighty Avengers when that was
the pro superhuman registration team
yeah with Aries and Wonderman and yeah
she had her own give a crap about yeah
that was yeah Marvel's like let's let's
make Herold ders popular again and and
people were like was she
ever yeah they were like well well
Marvel at some point was like I think it
was around House of M they were like we
should have a Wonder Woman maybe it'll
be Carol daners that's exactly what
happened she was married Wonder in House
of she was Wonder Woman like in in House
of em she's like she was the greatest
superhero on the planet and then they
and then they launched after House of M
The Miz Marvel Miner or it was it turned
out to be miniseries it was originally
an ongoing um in which she was like she
remembers what happened in the house of
am and she was like when I was in that
Universe I was the ever yeah I can
actually relate to this yeah and now I'm
not so I guess I'll try to be one which
I was like my girlfriend was like let's
read the like I want to read this
because I want to get into like a cool
new Marvel female superhero or not new
but you know a cool Marvel superhero and
she's like [__] Carol Danvers like she
read like half of that series and was
like I don't care about you like and
your stupid story because she was like
she wasn't really a hero she just wanted
to be one like and she was like kind of
forcing it like Alias is a great
superhero story about a character who's
like I wanted to be a superhero and then
I realized I suck at it that's a good
story that was that was the problem with
Carol Danver man is it was a great
character that Marvel had and they just
trashed it yep like they just totally
trashed her character like
she it it just comes down to they're
trying too hard yeah is great yeah
Marvel now yeah Captain Marvel's great
but like up until that point it was like
you know it just they just didn't think
hard enough they didn't get Gail
book they didn't get Kelly suit eonic on
that book like they needed somebody what
they were doing they should have L
Simonson to write that book that would
have beeny
amazing but yeah who else is left I
think that's all the stories right yeah
no so I mean we got uh I've converted
Drake so two for flasho one for Dark
Night returns and Rob's got something
about imagine J I'll just make I'll just
pick a Booster Gold story cred World The
Crooked World okay I could remember the
name of it honestly though oh my god um
okay so to end this up I'm I'm going to
go through here real quick see uh while
I'm going through some of the questions
guys don't you guys go ahead and let us
know what your favorite stories are and
the reasons why and I'll read up your
comments and we'll give everyone like a
one sentence response to it um while
we're waiting for your responses uh a
good friend of ours over on Twitter
world uh Cameron has linked a very
interesting story we can talk about for
the next five minutes while we're
waiting for the comments they have
announced the official cast for Suicide
Squad oh really yep Will Smith Tom Hardy
marget Robbie and Jared Leto I don't
know who any the people are oh dud Jared
Leto Jared letto man he found his claim
to fame and Rec him for a dream but yeah
is Jared Leto The
Joker Joker's never been on suicide
squad so I don't know I mean obviously
Margaret Rob Robbie is gonna be uh
Harley Quinn and Will Smith is gonna be
Black Manta I can see that well I'm
assuming on that one see this is all
Greek to me uh okay says so Smith Oh
Smith is gonna play Deadshot whoa he's
gonna be Deadshot Will Smith's gonna be
Deadshot yeah yeah that was like the
plan Leto is going to take on the jok oh
you're right yeah while Robbie will play
Harley Quinn so I got that one right and
his onof girlfriend Courtney will play
Boomerang um while Delan whatever
somebody turned after this is gonna play
panle and
chantress all right what's Tom Hardy
gonna play I can't find Fanboy I don't
even know who all these people are yeah
I have no idea who I'm looking up on my
phone like I have no idea who
imag to be involved in the movie and
since he's likes Luther that makes sense
the Brave and the Bold I thought the
Brave and the Bold was like strictly
created for like that cartoon
show the has been around for a long time
it was just 1959 yeah well the most
recent Incarnation is pretty much a
kids's version of it is and it's
hilarious have you not seen the birds of
prey song it's wonderful oh it's so
great many windows is Tom Hardy gonna be
Bane oh God Noe God Tom Hardy be
somebody else Bane was or Tom Hardy was
not a bad Bane his character was really
bad no I just mean like they're not
going to do that like they won't they
won't do that that's you stands a symbol
of amazing that' be amaz oh Harley
Quinn okay you know they'll they won't
be able to resist it they'll have him go
like you know like I read this guy named
B all right so uh Jeremy Renfro says
that John Constantine of hell isra is
also one of the few characters in comic
books that has actually aged over time
and that's true yes he is he's like in
his freaking 50s and it's awesome well
they finally reset him in the new video2
I know but but it was hilarious for a
while yeah he he was like 60 like I'm
taking on the
devil like okay all right old man have
fun uh Zach Munch says the podcast is
really cool thank you uh crazy comic
says there's too many Avengers groups
damn right and a couple people agreed
with him uh Rob your voice is lower than
everybody else's no it's not I'm just
going my microphone turned all the way
up people were like I can hear you just
fine so I said okay
um black Bol boligon says puberty is a
mutation so it does a lot of things to a
lot of different people I don't know
what that even Rel you'll grew a hair in
playes you didn't normally have
hair um Andrew Porter says he loved the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline awesome I
like that one was a good classic one
never read you never read Infinity
Gauntlet I'm getting around to it get to
it hey I just I I I'm reading from Civil
War up and then I'm reading from Marvel
now back
CU um like when you read Infinity gaunet
make sure you follow it up with uh
infinity war and um warlock in the
infinity watch okay oh no you got you
have to to get the full story because
you got to find out what happens after
The Infinity Gauntlet comes to an end I
totally want to hear about this Infinity
watch okay um what's it uh kronos's
asked why Drake has no camera we've
discovered he has an okay internet
connection if he just pretends to be
Iron Man uh hang on let me see
if shy uh says that Booster Gold of the
new 52 is their favorite storyline yeah
because Booster Gold's [__]
awesome but blackagar boligon says Vape
for years hashtag hashtag Vape for years
yeah pretty much I Vape all day uh House
of M for Ed Harper says it was his
favorite moment in the house of oh what
was our favorite moment in the House of
M uh mine was the crazy storyline they
did with Spider-Man I thought that was
cool worst Booster Gold story ever the
original it's pretty bad nice
um my favorite one is when um uh Magneto
tasks um apocalypse with going and uh
facing off against um black panther he
go he tells he tells him to go to
wakanda and tells to issue Black Panther
and ultimatum either they join Magneto's
side because again like wakanda's been
neutral this whole time either they join
Magneto or they'll be destroyed but when
apocalypse gets to wakanda like black
bolts there blackbolt like Whispers at
him yeah like he he opens his mouth and
like apoc is totally incinerated there's
like this mile long path of D that's
awesome I would love to see that fight
yeah it was something that needs to be
done what's your favorite cell uh from
the moan from the House of
M I don't know there wasn't really a lot
to like about that book you like to that
character that they created to fixa
Miller is so great a rich Chestnut
totally contributory to the rest of the
Marvel Universe um I I I liked uh I
liked um The Quiet Moments like uh
Magneto morning Professor X at the Rock
Memorial uh I liked uh I liked Hawkeye
shooting Wanda because he was like
incensed about being
murdered um I like the end with uh when
everybody's back and like they're all
like and like only only a few of them
remember um did you read
it Drake did you read it read
what yeah just assume that I
don't but uh I I've read the miss marble
thing and where she talks about House of
there you go I
mean I've heard it I've heard it's good
you know I watched the Marvel explains
on the X-Men and you know everybody like
oh they're getting rid of all the X-Men
so we have less mutants okay that's that
sounds interesting um I have a fuckload
of comics that I just bought for Black
Friday so whenever I finish reading
those is that you oh my god wow you got
all those on Black Friday good God
that's I didn't buy a single comic on
Black Friday I bought one video game I
spent $400 on Black Friday at comic book
store
that is all I did for Black Friday and
it is ridiculous I read most of it
because my my girlfriend's parents are
insufferable so I read those so I could
Escape um hope they're not watching
Thanksgiving not well yeah so I I've
read a bunch of comics to escape
Thanksgiving but that's why my my
collection has doubled one of the
coolest like undercurrents of the House
of M which is a story that like escaped
a lot of people is you had like Victor
Von Doom trying to usurp the role of
Magneto yeah and that was a really
really cool like under current story
like it was a big background story to
everything in the House of M but a lot
of people just forgot about it but it's
it's pretty cool like the Fantastic Four
are gone like Susan storm Reed Richards
Johnny Storm like they're all dead and
the only person that's left is the thing
and they call him the it so it's pretty
messed
up but it um okay uh well just so I yeah
we could House of I know Rob loves House
of M so we can be here all day well um
apparently uh shy he uh he said that 52
the story itself was when uh what he
liked about Booster Gold oh okay okay
yeah that and that was the the big
countdown everything I remember that
because that was the one where Batman
Superman and Wonder Woman would have
said we're taking a break for a year
that's doable head dies and everything
yeah okay so next thing we got a data
computation says his favorite stories
are the ones that Marvel explain tells a
what a suck up thank you thank you so
much animus is favorite story is Civil
War since it was the first story he read
Ray Knight agrees with him that's a good
reason uh black says his favorite story
is from the' 60s amazing spreader in
volume one number 50 and 51 the first
appearance of the Kingpin oh he's a good
vill that's not that's not a bad story
that's a good one pretty good you you Pi
also Spider-Man no more yeah
yeahman gave up his superhero Alias
yeah um and then everyone and the
brother for about 20 comments yelled at
me that Tom Hardy is going to be Rick
flag there you go last time I ask you
guys live on a
podcast uh Marco Marquez
villain maybe got that right my favorite
event is planet shut up planet Hulk um
oh see all right here here's the funny
thing about like Planet Hulk and World
War Hulk just gonna read it oh dude it's
it's so good everybody is everybody's
hoping that like Marvel is going to
bring like the whole planet Hulk story
into existence I don't think they will
yeah I don't think they will either I
mean you'd have a I mean it's too much
too much has to be done for that and to
put him on a planet where he like you
they would have to come up with an
excuse as to why's there they could they
could do that with Captain America 3 or
I guess I'm sorry Avengers 2 when uh I
guess Tony starts fighting him they
could just say all right look like
you're just too dangerous to be here and
they could just send him out into space
but the problem yeah the problem is you
can't do Planet Hulk without doing World
War Hulk and so they would have to do
World War Hulk at some
point you don't have to do warw Hulk
warw Hulk is totally dispensible you
could like you could have Hulk's like
arve
like you could have Hulk come back or
you could have them use the infinity
goet to bring him back like yeah you
don't have the reason he comes back
doesn't have to be to fight everybody
they could just something happens he has
to return home and then we okay no hang
on if they launch him into space I don't
think that he would be happy coming back
and hey I'm home now guys what's up
that's what happens in World War Hulk
like he comes back and he's
pissed soad you guys are not I got drunk
last night I woke up in a rocket I was
just going through space I don't even
know what happened so from what I read
um they they put Hulk in the rocket ship
just because it's it wouldn't be fair in
Civil War if if he was on a side same
reason why Doctor Strange is fasting the
entire time they found a way to they
decided to keep the century in Civil War
whatever yeah but and so like all that
is good whatever and so yeah obviously
he's out in space you got to do
something cool with that but I would
love to see that from what I know about
it I mean I'm sure it's awesome I've I
know the general bits that I've read on
Wikipedia of how Planet Hulk goes but if
we're doing Civil War in the mov to
whatever capacity we could probably see
it and it could probably just be like
John Carter yeah you know how that well
that really worked out for them didn't
it hey I liked the John Carter movie I
love million it made like 30 there's no
way they're ever gonna try that again oh
they actually are who did that there's
no Way's gonna make that risk again I
wouldn't they're making a sequel to it
from what I hear they're making a sequel
to a movie that lost 90% that that is
what I heard well cuz they're going to
try again they got to get this right
okay so crazy Comics says that his
favorite storyline is superior to
Spider-Man because of the battle between
the memories between Peter and the mind
of Dr Octopus read the first volume of
that [__] loved it I got to get
another um 185% juice I don't even know
what that supposed okay U says that his
is uh infinity War because Adam Warlock
dispels all good and evil from his soul
and then has to deal with it the Magus
the maggus comes back at the end of
infinity War you have goddess and you
have all you have all kinds of cool
stuff that goes on there is a pretty
good story oh I lost the place I had it
the amazing somebody said they like the
new Harley Quinn
run oh God the stupid the YouTube just
scrolled me down like 20 comments sorry
whoever I missed
over Hulk and World War Hulk for the win
what you say uh Fino saying that he's
really liking uh moonnight and I really
I I picked up the Marvel Now bit in of
it I lik uh the trait he's punching
ghosts and of course I like it yeah know
I I like the moonnight run the new one
they the viewers actually they kept do
moonnight do moonnight do moonnight so I
was like fine I'll get the stupid
moonnight train I'm like this is amazing
yeah I mean there was there was somebody
who was asking about about moonnight on
Reddit like they were talking about like
in Moon Knight's first appearance he was
like a werewolf Hunter and uh they were
like like what's going on like why
doesn't he do that anymore and and I was
basically like he's got multiple
personalities and Marvel just uses that
to write off any role that he's ever
played it's like well he's he was crazy
now he's Mr White or whatever it is no
he's CRA crazyer
Batman Warren Ellis's moonnight has
never been better like that book was
amazing and then they got rid of War
Ellis he I'm sure he left like he was
just like H well anyway I got it that
was fun let's go do something else
exactly well I had fun bye um but I hear
the new creative team has really been
picking like has been continuing that
that trend of success yeah I will also
throw out there by the way I think uh
just as far as great old story arcs are
gar denis's Punisher MAX oh he is really
really great is that when Punisher and
Eminem teamed up no that's when puner
all the the greatest stories ever
involving the Punisher when you think of
the Punisher and you think of like just
gratuitous murder like Punisher MAX okay
that's Tim Brad street cover art that's
uh the guy I worked with Andis on
preacher Steve Dylan mostly on pencils
it's really
really cool it's also like because like
Andis is like no G uh is always like uh
Frank Castle is a Vietnam veteran so he
was fought in Vietnam so G so Frank
Castle is 56 years old like he doesn't
even try to fit him in like there's
there's a really cool monologue from
Frank Castle like issue number 24 I
think or something like that maybe it's
21 but he's talking about how like like
it's it's crazy like he goes into this
building and just like starts shooting
it like killing everybody like all these
criminals but while he's doing that like
he's giving this monologue and he's he
talks about this dream that he has where
he uh he doesn't just like stop with
villains like he doesn't stop with like
quicked politicians like he kills like
all the people who are apathetic like he
just starts killing innocent people and
he wakes up before he actually kills
like before the before anybody dies but
dude Punisher MAX is like the definitive
Punisher series if you're going to read
anything Punisher you got to read
Punisher MAX they they need to bring
back Punisher in a good way the problem
is he's to 90s for nowadays I'm reading
I read I read the new one like I a
couple issues of the new where you moved
to LA and like that was neat not that
was neat that was okay they need to
reintroduce Punisher MAX again and
update it for the current time now that
we're hitting uh an hour and a half into
the podcast here I think it's about time
we start bringing it to a close we've
gone over our favorite stories we've
read a lot of your guys favorite stories
and please keep giving comments down
here I'm not sure Rob you're actually
going to take this down to reupload it
aren't you so since you're going to see
the original comments you guys need to
leave the new comments with what your
favorite stories are so that Rob out
comic Drake and I can all go back
through and agree or disagree or argue
with in the comments trust us Drake will
be on every comment that comes out on
this video I I I don't do that as much
anymore I I've had to stop I pissed off
some
people but um I know yours made me so
angry but uh all right so so for you
guys um out there listening in the world
of of YouTube and comic books um this
will be the last podcast we do for the
rest of the month and the reason why is
because I was going to say maybe no like
starting in like starting in January
like one is the holiday season so this
is the time when we're all hanging out
with our families and and spending time
with our families which of
course but you're what I'm turning 21 oh
nice we'll see you in a Year son of a
[__] that's why I grew the go I'll be
busy with birthday [__] and getting
really really really really
conratulations just get hammered over
Christmas yeah congratulations oh yeah
it will happen but um anyway like
January 1 there's some huge stuff coming
down the pipe and and with the podcast
we'll finally relaunch it as like
working the way that it should where we
won't have like audio problems and all
that kind of good stuff but um we we're
in contact with a uh with a writer for
Marvel Comics who is hopefully gonna
make it on the podcast starting in
January and I think you guys are really
going to love who we're bringing on
especially the character that he writes
but um yeah with the weekly pool and
everything launching in January uh this
this it's really really going to take
off in spectacular fashion and so all
this stuff the weekly pool podcast the
whole yards it's all going to come back
in January and it'll be rebooted like
Marvel style not that crappy DC should
we call it the weekly pool now or weekly
pool New 52
Edition we pull now that would be pretty
awesome I guess I guess I'm just never
making an appearance
again we replace you with a girl oh well
hang on or it'll be
me yeah good point up January 1st we're
going to launch the weekly pool.net
we're hoping for it it may be a week
after that but it's January is going to
be the official month that we launched
the website along with the proper
podcast along with everything that we're
trying to do for you guys and the
combination of everything and we've
doing a lot of work behind the scenes
and it's killing all of us and we're
just we're we're finding problems coming
up with topics like that Suicide Squad
thing we were done within like five
minutes so we we really need to we need
Marvel on them to stop taking Christmas
break and give us stuff yeah pretty much
pretty much but um but yeah just keeping
you guys in the loop making sure you
guys know what's going on so uh so yes
what does everybody have coming on for
the next few days or so
let's start with comic Drake are you
doing a video comic Drake well um I I'm
in the middle of editing my 5,000
subscriber special for my comic channel
uh I I'm getting all the audio together
I'm gonna be getting up I know Benny's
gonna be in it s's gonna be in it Rob is
Rob is busy as [__] so so I yeah uh
we're gonna be narrating uh Martian
Manhunter number 24 which is the comic
where Booster Gold and Blue Beetle steal
all Mar Man Hunter cookies and he goes
on a Hulk like Rampage so I'm editing
all that together it's a lot of fun uh
Kerber first coming on to uh Blue Beetle
and then after that I'm working on a
giant episode of explaining the origins
of all the different Lantern cores not
really the entities or the emotional
Spectrum just this is where when this
core began this is when this core began
and that's why I was taking a little
break so I could really write it down
get all my facts checked and make it one
awesome video
nice yeah
go I'm gonna be doing um we didn't do
any off the racks this week it's all
tangents all the time it's going to be
like nonstop tangents Thursday um
because I have over two hours of
tangents um but uh yeah there're people
seem to like them they're they're really
quick they're really great introduction
to this to the channel and to the to the
people that are on the channel um and uh
and then it gives you a good good
appetizer for Thursday's episode of back
issues which will be uh about fear
itself the the Forgotten Marvel event
what what Spar I hear it never existed
that's that's where that's where fear is
literally afraid of
itself it's literally stupid but
uh I'm loving these podcast suggestions
for the names the allnew weekly po all
new weekly poll the weekly pollar week
po allar weekly po Superior weekly
po can we can we do like a weekly po
original
sin you guys are not going to believe
the original sin that we all forgot
about was there was another host not not
other people it was another host that no
one knew about no his name was mad Jim
and okay I was with you for a while like
okay I'm
done um I was trying to wait make it up
was like go was it working no it was not
working at all all right over what's
going on over here at Marvel explain the
host of our podcast right now well as
you guys know like we're doing the whole
Age of Apocalypse thing but then I
started going I started going through my
comments and I realized a couple things
one I never re-uploaded Civil War part
six two we never concluded the events of
Wolverine in Civil War and three like
wait Civil War part six is missing yeah
it's not I well I had to delete it
because of a copyright thing and I meant
to reupload it but I never did and so
yeah people have been like hounding me
and I was I was going through like all
the comments because I usually check
like the first few videos or so that I
upload with the comments and then I was
like I saw like all these comments for
civil war and I was like what in the
hell so I went back and looked and it's
like Civil War part 7 is like part six
is missing part six is missing and I was
like oh my God so so I have to re-upload
part six I actually have to go back and
remake it so I have to redo part six
we've got a close out wol rain from
Civil War so we could figure out what
was going on with him and what what all
took place and then we've got to close
out Civil War and then we've got to
cover the death of Captain America so oh
yeah we're gonna have to put Age of
Apocalypse on
hold so that'll be fun but uh in January
I think we'll be able to pick back up
with it again nice yeah cool oh um
really quick I'll just I'll just take
this opportunity to mention yeah what's
this tease s what's this te oh they the
May oh yeah people want to know if we're
ever going to do World War Hulk on on
back issues and I don't know about that
but I we do know that we are coming out
with a Christmas special yes yes I can't
wait to see this I want to be on the
last one we're doing for the month um uh
do Christmas specials for no reason I've
been doing them for four years now uhas
literally just a Christmas special of
life like me and my friends what happens
in that Christmas special actually
happens this sound Robin I visited his
life is that crazy it's really like that
to TV little house you will see like we
do you know we did a Christmas special
where like my co-host Ethan tries to
save the economy three years ago and
that's why things turned around uh the
next year Santa Claus came to visit and
we had to fight Eva leprechaun uh that
was like H Frain Roger Rabbit level
quality right there and then the third
one uh Christmas 365 um Christmas is
coming you know earlier and earlier uh
so we try to stop that yeah gonna be
like an all year thing yeah and then
yeah that's the idea is the Christmas is
C like we're gonna be celebrating it in
like in like February you know it's like
so to be Christmas 365 uh that's the
idea there and then this new that's
coming out hopefully on Christmas Day if
not a little earlier than that um will
be Ben in space it's literally just
guardiance the
Galaxy I can't wait to see that yeah
it's a love letter to like to like the
original Star Wars and like and
Guardians and stuff like that
incidentally we started shooting that
movie we started shooting this this
special like three four months before
Guardians even came out like I just I
just want to state that S I think you
have too much time in your hands I no
sir no sir I disagree if time on his
hand produces content like this like he
should have a lot more time on his hand
exactly I like yeah we couldn't do off
the rack because I was editing this
stupid thing that like a quarter of our
will watch but yeah the teasers on the
site you can check it out it's called
the last time follow as long as you
enjoyed making it that's what that's
what it comes down I put out some videos
that I know are not going to get me a
lot of views but I put them out and I'm
like I had fun and that's all that
matters what it is it's just for me
and since I put out a video that no
one's going to watch now I'm going to
put out three that they will yeah I am
sorry this is my apology letter you know
we should just do right after the
special comes out I should do war war
Hulk Deadpool uh that do like M with a
mouth yeah the origins of Batman I'm
really sorry and then I'll just start
explaining story arcs but yeah okay um I
guess it's my turn or you still got more
Robson no no no that's you're good okay
um so I've kind of planned out this
month like a whole month because of the
whole situation that's going on um it's
kind of like a Superman Batman kind of
deal uh that I'm doing for most of this
month which I'm going I'm doing Marvel
don't worry guys I'll leave people
freaking out I Deadpool's coming out
today I got more Marvel zombies coming
out I've got uh I'm planning to do World
War Hulk actually it was going to be as
a Christmas gift to S but I guess I'll
just R it
now but I was going to do World War Hulk
and plan at Hulk and all that stuff and
that's all this month but when I'm
planning for DC and this is my kind of
like big thing I'm doing is I'm going to
do one of my classic stories cuz I don't
do them often but I'm working on the
killing joke because you got to explain
where the Joker came from before I can
do death of the family you know you
can't just jump in death of the family
uh and I'm doing Superman and I'm going
to explain Super Boy Super Boy primed
because everyone's been asking for that
forever now what about the super boys
yeah the punch the punch oh the reality
punch yay the reality punch crisis what
was that one was it like the punch that
broke reality or something like that
yeah yeah it broke reality he punched it
so hard he shattered reality that and
that's was that was that in was that
Infinite Crisis it was crisis on
infinite Earths yeah infinite Earths was
the 80s one I always get the two mixed
up it's the one that came second and
because final Cris is the third is the
second one all right yeah final crisis
is third then flasho I want to say it's
final or CR it's one of them either way
I'm going to cover a bunch of CP was but
I'm working on the killing joke and what
I am working on cuz a lot of people
asking what I'm going to pick up the
rest of the Jeff John's run is blitzing
through Jeff John's in January is my
plan just do Green Lantern War of the
lanterns first l J you know just just
knock them all out just get it done get
Green Lantern caught up just Jeff John's
Green Lantern or Jeff John's in general
with Aquaman all that other no no no
Jeff John's Green Lantern run so I get
Green Lantern con up to current day so I
can do current Day Green Lantern stuff
okay that's cool yeah yeah forever
weekly uh the weekly po house ofp I like
I like uh I like Born
Again these are cool these are really
good names but yeah so better than the
ones we came up with so today I'm coming
out today I'm coming out with the
Deadpool original sin story which is the
story of him finding his daughter
finally and that whole thing that'll be
coming out in a little bit and later
this week should be Marvel Zombies along
with Kryptonite explanations for the
record two fun ones that I found doing
my research I did not I was not aware of
the pink one that how did you not know
that I don't
know there's a pink Kryptonite that
turns kryptonians into
homosexuals [__] yeah there's also a
purple spotted one that causes
Kryptonian dogs to chase their tail you
know I could imagine I imagine like this
big rave on like Krypton that they would
have every year and like they have like
yeah they all just like start deling in
or they have like a giant like pink
Krypton like ball well consider night is
the Radio Active Home world the world
would have had to
explode I would say raave there was
fireworks like the greatest Rave ever
but yeah so that that's what I'm doing
I've got a lot of stuff planned I'm
still happy I don't know why I'm doing
this all right uh anything you guys want
to say in the way out the door no I
think we're good okay uh man for the
record it has become a cave in my room
this wasn't this dark before it
wasn't so what's zal playing in the back
uh today she is playing Lords of the
Fallen oh sweet I Skyrim for a minut I
was looking at that I was like that kind
of looks like Skyrim but maybe it's not
why uh okay uh age of pole uh fin
suggesting Patron Patron I always say
it's Patron I know it's patreon but I
always call Patron because I always want
to get drunk after hearing about
it all right and uh and they're all
agreeing that a Krypton Rave would be
amazing and I guess on that note we'll
be ending today's podcast I'm Benny the
comic story and that is Comic Drake of
Drake's the Drake car stuff that is s of
TV little House's Christmas special and
that is Rob of the Marvel explained hour
where he forgot to upload a
[Laughter]
video uh got nothing else I guess you
guys can go check out of our channels
Rob annotate all of us on this video
yeah I
[Music]
will click somewhere to subscribe yeah
well I mean I'll do it like in the post
processing when I upload it and we'll
see you guys in uh January I guess uh
you can always get a hold of us through
Twitter we're always chatting on Twitter
s retweets anything you tweet it's funny
y all right well uh yeah man we'll catch
you guys
later